(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
NOW, LOOK, THIS IS GOING TO BE
TOUGH, BUT WE REALLY DO WANT TO
FOCUS ON TEXAS -- SPECIFICALLY
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE SANDRA
BLAND INCIDENT.
IT'S GOTTEN SO MANY PEOPLE
TALKING BECAUSE SO MUCH OF IT
REALLY DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
A WOMAN WAS PULLED OVER FOR A
TRAFFIC STOP, AND A FEW DAYS
APPARENTLY COMMITS SUICIDE IN A
JAIL CELL.
THERE'S STILL A LOT TO UNPACK IN
THIS STORY.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT.
LET'S JUST LOOK AT THE DASHCAM
VIDEO THAT WAS RELEASED.
>> YOU OKAY?
I'M WAITING ON YOU.
THIS IS YOUR JOB.
WHAT YOU WANT ME TO DO?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
YOU SEEM VERY IRRITATED.
>> I AM.
I REALLY AM, BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE
THIS IS CRAP FOR WHAT I'M
GETTING A TICKET FOR.
I WAS GETTING OUT OF YOUR WAY.
YOU WERE SPEEDING AND TAILING
ME.
SO I MOVE OVER.
AND YOU STOP ME.
SO, YEAH, I AM IRRITATED, BUT
THAT DOESN'T STOP YOU FROM
GIVING ME A TICKET SO --
>> ARE YOU DONE?
Larry: OKAY.
THIS IS THE FIRST ESCALATION.
YOU ASKED HER THE QUESTION.
SHE ANSWERED IT, AND THEN YOU
GOT A LITTLE SNIPPY.
"ARE YOU DONE?" ISN'T HOW YOU
FINISH SOMETHING.
"ARE YOU DONE?" IS HOW YOU START
SOMETHING.
(LAUGHTER)
RIGHT?
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
JUST SAYIN'.
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYIN'.
OKAY?
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO KNOW
WHAT HE'S STARTING RIGHT NOW IS
AN ESCALATION.
>> YOU ASKED ME WHAT'S WRONG AND
I TOLD.
>> OKAY.
SO NOW I'M DONE, YEAH.
OKAY.
YOU MIND PUTTING OUT YOUR
CIGARETTE, PLEASE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: OKAY.
SHE SAID SHE WAS DONE.
AND YOU KEPT ON GOING.
"YOU MIND PUTTING OUT YOUR
CIGARETTE, PLEASE?" IS THE
DEFINITION OF NOT BEING
INTERESTED IN DONE.
YOU'RE FISHING FOR UNDONENESS.
ALL RIGHT?
NOW, LOOK, I'M NOT SAYING IT'S
THE BEST IDEA TO BE SMOKING A
BUTT WHEN A COP PULLS YOU OVER.
BUT YOU'RE ALLOWED TO.
ALL RIGHT?
AND IT DEFINITELY SHOULDN'T
RESULT IN THIS:
>> I'M IN MY CAR.
WHY DO I HAVE TO PUT OUT MY
CIGARETTE?
>> YOU CAN STEP ON OUT NOW.
I DON'T HAVE TO STEP OUT OF
MY CAR.
>> STEP OUT OF THE CAR.
STEP OUT OF THE CAR.
>> NO, YOU DON'T HAVE THE
RIGHT --
>> STEP OUT OF THE CAR.
YOU DO NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DO THAT.
>> I DO HAVE THE RIGHT.
NOW STEP OUT OR I WILL REMOVE
YOU.
>> I REFUSE TO TALK TO YOU OTHER
THAN TO IDENTIFY MYSELF --
>> GET OUT OR I WILL REMOVE YOU.
I AM GETTING REMOVED FOR A
FAILURE TO SIGNAL?
>> STEP OUT OR I WILL REMOVE
YOU.
I'M GIVING YOU A LAWFUL ORDER.
GET OUT OF THE CAR NOW, OR I'M
GOING TO REMOVE YOU.
>> AND I'M CALLING MY --
I'M GOING TO YANK YOU OUT OF
HERE.
>> OKAY.
YOU'RE GOING TO YANK ME OUT OF
MY CAR?
>> GET OUT.
Larry: OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DO THIS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO.
DON'T TOUCH ME.
GET OUT OF THE CAR!
I'M NOT UNDER ARREST.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO --
>> YOU ARE UNDER ARREST.
I'M UNDER ARREST FOR WHAT?
25-47 F.M. 298, SEND ME A
UNIT.
GET OUT OF THE CAR!
GET OUT OF THE CAR NOW!
>> WHY AM I BEING APPREHENDED?
YOU'RE TRYING TO GIVE ME A
TICKET FOR FAILURE --
>> I SAID GET OUT OF THE CAR.
WHY AM I BEING APPREHENDED?
YOU OPEN MY CAR DOOR --
>> I'M GOING TO DRAG YOU OUT OF
HERE.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO DRAG ME OUT
OF MY OWN CAR?
>> GET OUT OF THE CAR!
I WILL LIGHT YOU UP!
GET OUT!
>> WOW.
NOW!
WOW!
GET OUT OF THE CAR!
Larry: OKAY.
HERE'S WHAT I SAW.
I SAW A WOMAN WHO WAS VERY
IRRITATED, PROBABLY HAVING A BAD
DAY -- MOST LIKELY BECAUSE SHE
WAS PULLED OVER -- SMOKING A
CIGARETTE TO CALM DOWN, COMPLIED
WITH EVERYTHING THE OFFICER
ASKED FOR.
THEN IT GOT CONFUSING BECAUSE HE
TOLD HER TO PUT OUT HER
CIGARETTE BUT THEN OFFERED TO
LIGHT HER UP BY POINTING A TASER
AT HER HEAD.
TO ME AND MOST REASONABLE
PEOPLE, IT'S VERY CLEAR THIS
OFFICER WAS WRONG.
>> IF YOU ARE BEING STOPPED BY A
POLICE OFFICER, WHETHER THAT
POLICE OFFICER IS RIGHT OR
WRONG, DON'T YOU DO WHAT HE SAYS
UNTIL AFTERWARDS.
THEN YOU CAN SUE HIM.
THEN YOU'RE STILL ALIVE.
>> Larry: OKAY, FIRST OF ALL, I
DON'T KNOW WHO YOU'RE YELLING
AT.
[ AUDIENCE BOOs ]
SECONDLY, SHOULD ONE BE ON ONE'S
BEST BEHAVIOR WHEN THE COP PULLS
ONE OVER?
IDEALLY, YES.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, THE COP IS
A PROFESSIONAL.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
RIGHT?
SHOULD HE NOT HAVE BEEN ON SUCH
A POWER TRIP?!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
NOW I'M YELLING, DON LEMON.
(LAUGHTER)
LET ME CALM DOWN FOR A SECOND.
IT'S EASY TO SAY, BLACK PEOPLE,
WHY AREN'T YOU ACTING LIKE THE
DOWAGER COUNTESS WHEN A COP
PULLS YOU OVER?
(LAUGHTER)
"OH, HELLO, OFFICER.
I'M SO PLEASED YOU'VE
UNEXPECTEDLY DROPPED IN ON ME!
AH!
(LAUGHTER)
WOULD YOU LIKE SOME TEA?
I BREW IT IN MY GLOVE
COMPARTMENT."
(LAUGHTER)
NEXT TO MY STASH OF WEED THAT I
HAVE.
(LAUGHTER)
YES, THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND, THE FACT
THAT WE LIVE IN A WORLD WHERE
BLACK PEOPLE HAVE TO STRATEGIZE
SO THEY'RE NOT BRUTALIZED BY
POLICE IS INSANE.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S DON LEMON.
WHAT DOES FOX HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
THIS?
(LAUGHTER)
I'M NOT SURE IF I CAN WATCH.
>> THERE WAS NO REASON
WHATSOEVER TO ARREST HER.
SHE DIDN'T HAVE TO LISTEN TO HIM
FOR THAT REASON.
SHE HAD TO GIVE HIM HER DRIVER'S
LICENSE AND HER INFORMATION AND
THAT WAS IT.
>> WHY IS SHE IN JAIL FOR THREE
DAYS?
>> ON $5,000 BAIL!
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN INTENSE
INVESTIGATION.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: THIS IS HOW YOU KNOW
HOW [ BLEEP ] CRAZY A SITUATION
IS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
RIGHT?
WHEN I TOTALLY AGREE WITH WHITE
PEOPLE WHO ARE TALKING ABOUT
RACE ON FOX.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
RIGHT?
OH!
THAT'S HOW CRAZY IT IS.
ANYONE ELSE WHO I ALWAYS
VEHEMENTLY DISAGREE WITH ALSO
GETTING THIS RIGHT?
ANYONE?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS TERRIBLE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Larry: YOU'VE GOT TO BE
[ BLEEP ] ME!
(LAUGHTER)
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS TERRIBLE.
I THOUGHT HE WAS SO AGGRESSIVE.
IT WAS A TRAFFIC SIGNAL, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, AND, YOU KNOW,
WHO GETS OUT OF A CAR FOR A
TRAFFIC SIGNAL?
I'M A HUGE FAN OF THE POLICE,
BUT THIS GUY WAS OVERLY
AGGRESSIVE.
TERRIBLY AGGRESSIVE.
>> Larry: EVEN TRUMP AGREES?!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
RIGHT?
OH.
OKAY.
WE HAVE LOST CABIN PRESSURE.
(LAUGHTER)
PUT YOUR MASK ON FIRST.
ALL RIGHT.
BUT IN ALL SERIOUSNESS, THERE'S
A LOT OF SPECULATION IN THE
MEDIA AND ONLINE RIGHT NOW ABOUT
WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED TO SANDRA
BLAND.
SOMETIMES THE MOST RATIONAL
THING TO SAY IS "I DON'T KNOW."
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
SANDRA, AND TO ENGAGE IN A
GUESSING GAME ABOUT HOW SHE
PASSED THIS OR THAT, IT CAN BE
RECKLESS.
BUT I DO KNOW THAT THE RACIAL
CLIMATE IS SUPERCHARGED RIGHT
NOW.
WE JOKED ABOUT IT EARLIER, BUT
THE BLACK COMMUNITY IS ON EDGE.
AND IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME TO
SEE A BLACK WOMAN GET IRRITATED
WITH A POLICE OFFICER.
JUST AS IT DOESN'T SURPRISE ME
TO SEE A POLICE OFFICER NEGLECT
TO DE-ESCALATE A TENSE
SITUATION.
(APPLAUSE)
I MEAN, TO ME --
IT ALMOST FEELS LIKE THEY WERE
TWO PLAYERS IN A GREEK TRAGEDY
MARCHING TOWARD AN INEVITABLE
CONCLUSION.
SANDRA BRAND IS ONE VICTIM.
BUT HER STORY SPEAKS TO A LARGER
ISSUE.
AN ISSUE WE SHOULD BE TRYING TO
SOLVE BEFORE IT BECOMES A
PROBLEM AGAIN.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE).